hey you just broke news about your
colonoscopy and now no scary huh yes
funny when people like what that just
comes up like we just talking in my
colonoscopy club cuz I was doing it as a
joke I thought it was gonna be funny I
was going yeah it turned out to not
really be funny I was blogging it but
you know maintaining your health man is
so critical
alright so this character disguise well
not even disguise himself turns into a
pigeon when have you ever gone in
disguise
listen let me tell you I went for the
first time probably about three years
ago I went out for Halloween in disguise
hand and I realize it's a whole lot
better when people know you will smoke
because they treat you a lot too like we
stood out in front of a club for about
25 minutes and I was like I'm not doing
this as a dude listen I need to get up
in here I like me will Smith more than
disguise hey Alphonse was gonna host our
show tomorrow do you have any advice to
him or how do you think he will do let
me tell you something that boy is a born
performer like when I when I came on to
Fresh Prince you know I was the least
experienced person on that set you know
by the time I got on that set Alfonso
was 15 years of experience in in the
business you know he don't need my
advice I need advice from him
[Music]